son épopée est terminée il faut
maintenant trouver ce qui a mis fin une
équipe de médecine vétérinaire s'est
attardé à la nécropsies de façon
minutieuse chaque tissus et organes ont
été examinés ce qu'on peut dire c'est
que l'animal présentait quand même des
signes de traumatisme possible s'il y
avait présence des matons d'hémorragie
qui peuvent faire qui suggèrent
fortement que l'animal a été frappé par
un bateau à l'examen démontre aussi
qu'il s'agissait d'une toute petite
femelle âgée entre deux et trois ans de
plus de 10 mètres de long et qui pesait
17 tonnes
elle a été observée à la fin du mois de
mai au port de montréal très loin de son
habitat naturel
puis elle a été retrouvée morte près de
varennes malgré les grands efforts
déployés pour éviter le pire
on a donné à l'animal le plus de
protection possible les agents pêches et
océans canada ont été avec l'animal
pendant plusieurs jours le chp est né
savait c'est dommage de voir une belle
balade comme sous l'ombrelle de
seulement 3 l de visa donne un beau
spectacle avant mort et pourquoi c'était
l'aventuré aussi loin dans les eaux du
fleuve saint laurent
peut-être par curiosité ou encore par
gourmandise c'est peut-être un animal
qui était désorientée ou un gourmand qui
auraient suivi des poissons mais chose
certaine c'est qu'ils étaient dans un
habitat qui est pas approprié la baleine
de montréal n'a pas réussi à regagner
son territoire mais heureusement la
population des rares cas la bosse est en
expansion
chercheurs espèrent aussi que les
citoyens en tirons une leçon j'espère
qu'elle va laisser une trace indélébile
rappeler aux gens que seulement quatre
ou cinq cents kilomètres en aval du pont
jacques-cartier vivent ces animaux
mythiques ces animaux magnifiques
et si mélissa françois radio canada
montréal